okay so the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special trailer is now here
Marvel this week have given us jingle
balls to the wall trailers and along
with Ant-Man and the WASP quando Mania
we now have this throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down the
first look talking about the Easter eggs
in it and also going over our thoughts
for how this ties in with the future of
the MCU Guardians of the Galaxy 3 is
right around the corner too and having
already seen the trailer for it I have
some theories about what the special
gift will be here on top of this there's
also some plot leaks and cameos that we
have word on so if you don't want
anything ruined then I recommend that
you turn off now without the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
our Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special breakdown
foreign
[Music]
the calendar that right now on Earth
it's almost Christmas time we don't have
time for trivialities like Christmas but
Peter's so sad about Gamora being gone
we go to Earth they're a really
wonderful Christmas gift
it would make him happy
[Music]
something special you will never forget
what about someone special
[Music]
we are looking for the legendary Kevin
Bacon we're looking for the legendary
Kevin Bacon
I think maybe he didn't hear you
you're coming with us as a Christmas
present
[Music]
[Music]
okay so the last time we saw the group
they were leaving Thor behind so he
could go and see what lady sif's
distress call was we didn't get any
closure on the search for Gamora and
sadly I don't think this holiday special
will reunite the pair due to what
happens in the Guardians volume 3
trailer this was shown at d23 and we
know from that that the pair meet at a
ravager Meetup rather than here this is
after nebula organizes it so at best I
think this special might end with her
doing that so that it sets up the
meeting obviously the firing of James
Gunn had a lot of impact on Thor and
Guardians 3 as they were meant to be the
other way around in terms of release
dates so I kind of see this as being
something that might just smooth things
up give us some quality time with the
family and then set up the things that
we're gonna be getting in the next movie
James Gunn has been very young open
about what the holiday special entails
and he stated that it's going to be 40
minutes long and predominantly take
place on nowhere this was seemingly left
in ruin during Avengers Infinity War but
it's meant to be back on its feet or or
head though the trailer makes it clear
it's featuring a journey to Earth this
is where the story starts off at and
where most of the cast will stay while
the others go to Earth and the trailer
starts off with Peter walking through
the streets of the location looking sad
and glum the rest of the Guardians then
decide that they're gonna make the best
Christmas they can for him this includes
mantis Drax nebula and kraglan who might
have lost his wife after last time and
the concept of the special is basically
about Peter trying to love Christmas
once more yondu ruined the holiday for
him when he was younger and this will
very much be a scrooge sort of thing
where he learns to love the magical
holiday again yay no one nowhere they'll
go through the Christmas fun that we get
up to on Taran and this will make Peter
learn alongside Groot that it's all
about firmly we then see the Guardians
traveling on a new shape through a hex
Point not sure what the ship is as they
should still have the old one but hex
points are of course jump points that
allow travelers to hurt themselves
across space they land at the Hollywood
sign and stroll the streets of LA
including the Walk of Fame which we can
see by the stars on the ground
interestingly Drax is wearing a hoodie
and I I guess he no longer has sensitive
nipples which is nice there's also
Madame two swords and back on nowhere
rocket lights up the location there's
lots of partying too and I did pause the
footage to see if there were any people
amongst them that stood out but
unfortunately it just seems like extras
at this point we get one of the big
rumors from the series confirmed but
weeks now there's been reports that
Kevin Bacon will star on the special
this is confirmed by them showing up to
his house to kidnap him Kevin Bacon was
of course Peter's childhood hero and
watching them burst through his house
and then chase him down the street is
absolutely hilarious Kevin's movie
Footloose was given another two in
Avengers Infinity war and this special
will apparently Focus very heavily on
him now we also have a rumor that Silver
Surfer will be in this special too take
this with a big grain of salt and it
might not even be him as the leeks just
list him as the surfer rather than the
Silver Surfer with it being in space
though man the only character that
really surfs everyone in this spoiler
versus kind of jumped to conclusions and
assumed it's him there are rumors
floating around that he will be getting
his own special presentation very soon
and that this will be in the same vein
as werewolf by Knight I think this is
probably the best way to introduce the
character to the MCU as I actually
prefer that former over the Disney Plus
shows we've had our good ones and bad
ones but the special presentations just
seem to tell a story that they want to
tell rather than dragging and putting it
out for us to come back every week a
Silver Surfer is of course the herald of
Galactus and his appearance might slowly
tease towards civil ends arrival whilst
Kang is being propped up as the main
thread at the moment we also have some
others that could be coming very soon
Galactus is one of them and this
potential at Doctor Doom could be right
around the corner as well that's the
most spoilery thing anyway anyway and
let us know below who you'd like to see
in the special the trailer ends with us
getting a couple of cast members
including Cosmos the space dog who we
know will be voiced by Maria bakalova
it's very nice to see her involved in
the project though we don't get to hear
what she sounds like good is grown from
a team too and according to the leaks on
Guardians 3 he will become emperor Grid
at some point now on top of the gift of
Kevin Bacon I'm guessing they'll also be
getting something else I have a theater
Duty time and the group might even be
given their comic book Acura costumes by
my boy rocket in endgame he of course
wore the blue suit with a red scarf and
though we don't see it in the trailer
apparently he's gonna have it in the
special too the Lego set is already
leaked showing him in that and I think
he's gonna possibly end up giving the
rest of the group them as presence he of
course was on his own during endgame so
he had it just made for himself and this
will of course make the group more
online with the comics and just be a
nice little gift for Christmas so yeah I
think that's the way they're gonna go
with it and we have a scene where
they're all in festive jumpers the
special will be released on November
25th and this will be one month before
Christmas and a day after Thanksgiving
so it all falls in that festive period
and that's the trailer and as for my
thoughts yeah you know the job by now
with anything on Disney plus you don't
go in expecting too much and you'll
probably just have a fun time if you go
in with very low expectations but Kevin
didn't you just do a thing about
Galactus and the Silver Surfer well yes
Timmy I did but we know the Disney plus
format by now and these are mainly fun
little events with the mega stuff being
safe for the movies so based off that
yeah I'm a bit excited I don't think I'm
gonna be waking up at 7am rushing to
make sure I check it out but I think
it'll be an okay thing to fill up a
morning based off this teaser that will
be cracking anyone's top 10 MCU list but
as something I tied us over until
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 I think
it's gonna be serviceable anyway I'd
love to hear your thoughts on it in the
comments below do you think it's gonna
be Marvel's biggest project of all time
dear and I know you do mate so yeah
leave it in the comments below now we
are in competition right now and giving
away three copies of top gun Maverick on
the 15th of November and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the trailer
we pick the comments at random on the
15th and the winners of the last one are
on screen right now so that's you
message me on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want to mail to watch make sure
you check out our breakdown of the
Ant-Man trailer which will be linked on
screen right now sorry Ant-Man in the
WASP not sexist at the channel as you
can hear and we've proved it there so
yeah go check that out right after this
but out the way thanks for clicking the
video I'm off before I get canceled you
take care yourself peace